hi
um can i ask you really quickly um
because i as a on the feeder of who's
the boss and one of my favorite shows
ever on the history of television
is it true that you and tony danza are
doing a reboot we are in development for
a reboot yes
i know i know
one of the things that i read which i
thought was such an astute comment is
you said if we are to do a show
may it reflect its forward thinking
now as it was then because it's true
there was a woman running the house
there is a woman running a business a
man running the house is doing you know
all the housekeeping uh she was a single
mother had her own business had a
promiscuous
grandma on the show
yes the best and then you know tony was
taking care of the household and the
kids so there was that that role
reversal too so
i'm i'm really excited for what we can
do with this potential reboot it's it's
really exciting and it's i think gonna
be about you know that my husband leaves
me i have my own career and he comes to
take care of my kids oh my gosh
oh i love this i just got chills
everywhere yeah
yeah i think it could be really i think
it could be really great okay um in
honor of the title of your book i was
wondering if you would play a quick
speed round of a silly game called sorry
not sorry
i love it okay good i love silly games
[Music]
as we take on life's greatest challenges
i will list off a few moments of your
life that were completely
fun and interesting
and
maybe you could tell me if you're sorry
not sorry
okay are you ready i'm ready i'm so
ready okay sorry not sorry for your
tattoos
not sorry yeah good me neither um love
every single one want more um okay sorry
not sorry for your singing career as a
teen which by the way we all loved hello
not sorry yeah good okay good i'm not
sorry sorry not sorry for kissing a pig
on on tv
yes sorry okay
yeah
i'm sorry i feel like i already know the
answer to this question sorry not sorry
you clap back at an internet troll
oh not sorry yeah i know i knew that one
i'm sorry you are so emboldened i i
really admire your strength um sorry not
sorry for dating both corey feldman and
haim
i never dated feldman oh my god i never
dated haine but i dated feldman
i never dated feldman just came
well guess what once again together our
two halves make a hole oh
yeah i love you so much i wish i could
hug you i loved growing up with you i
love being an adult with you and a woman
and a mother and
may we continue
our journeys aligned and please pick up
a copy of this very very very powerful
book and um it's in stores it's amazing
you're amazing alyssa milano love you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]